does your hand look like my wife's hand
do your fingers fold down along two
major lines a distal and proximal crease
most human hands do but for about 15
percent of the population it's not that
simple for example on my left hand my
distal crease fuses with my proximal
crease creating a single fold line all
the way across my hand and on my right
hand a bridge crease connects both lines
meaning that my hand folds again along
just one fold line they're sometimes
called Simeon lines I guess because they
make your hands look like little monkey
person hands medical professionals tend
to just call them single Traverse Palmer
creases if they refer to them at all the
major creases of the Palm have not shown
to have much predictive power when it
comes to health or medical issues
they're just kind of random like
fingerprints fingerprints freak me out
there are Swirls and Loops form at
random in the womb not according to
instructions from your DNA so identical
twins may have the same genome but they
won't share the same fingerprints